a couple of months ago if you remember
this but I bumped into you okay turns
out our kids we didn't know this but our
kids are in the same basketball league
ours mine's a six year old boy my boy
but he still almost as tall as you yes
he's which is not fair cuz my son is
like you know 411 he can't even go on
the rides at the amusement park yet no
my son it's hard being six for when
you're six years old but when the but
we're in the same basketball league and
you and you show up and of course we're
both from Boston we're both die-hard
Celtics fans we know that about each
other man what's the big problem okay
here's the problem my son all of his
friends are on a certain team yeah here
in Los Angeles in the league and that's
the one my son wanted to play on all he
wanted to be on the lake he wanted to be
on the Lakers and this is cause he just
wanted to be with his friends and it
happened to be the Lakers and he said
dad I want to be on that team it was
really hard for me I said he could my
son walks out and you see me and you're
like who's your son planform you look
over you see all these kids went out in
Lakers Jersey no I thought you were
gonna hit me in the Adam's apple
well I wouldn't hit you in the face but
I couldn't reach you know what as funny
as my son just happened to randomly get
picked on the Celtics yeah my wife
caught me is all you're gonna be excited
because he got picked on the Celtics I
was like that's awesome then she was
like what we're gonna put him on another
team because one of his friends can't
make it to practice on Wednesday and I
said I don't give a [ __ ] what and that's
it but my kids actually they consider
themselves California's because they
were born here sure so like you know I
took my daughter a Lakers game and you
know Kobe's like oh she's a big Celtics
fan right like and she's like no I'm
from California I like you guys they
sell us out
they don't care you know what it is what
it is as long as as long as my son
doesn't punch me in the nuts anymore I'm
fine that's that that's his nose goes
through that face him and then
three-year-old yeah I think they came to
visit me in Miami I was on the set with
a rock and I said my kids really love
you can you come by and say hi so
they're in the trailer he gives my one
son a high five and then the next one he
goes to get my high five my son right
nuts really yeah I'm like what are you
doing dude he looks at me like I made
him do it or something that was gonna
try like I wish we had footage of that
that's his new thing well I'll invite
him on the show one day he'll punch it
I want that yeah are you when I saw you
at the basketball game at our kids
basketball game you were still we were
both absorbing the Patriots loss because
we're both Patriots fans and you I was
upset
you were just catatonic I mean you were
just beside yourself I was worried for
your mental health about the Patriots
loss and it was shortly after they lost
the Super Bowl how are you doing now
well I'm still grieving but the biggest
problem was and the reason why I was
really upset was because I got in so
much trouble I had a bunch of friends
over watching the game you know Patriots
were winning pretty much the whole game
right they lose in the last couple of
seconds I had 15 friends over I kicked
everybody out I like literally get the F
out now and then my wife comes in she
goes they take it easy it's only a game
and I went what and that was where the
real problem story yeah you don't do
that because she was so upset I wasn't
able to make it up to her until
Valentine's Day which was the next month
actually you know the same month so it
was pretty close so thank God but she's
still like three weeks four you're
sleeping in the garage she's actually
hoping now she said you know you're
never watching the game again but now
she just hopes that the Patriots make it
back to the Super Bowl so she'd go in
like a week vacation during the Super
Bowl
yeah and just leave you uh but it was it
was bad you know and hopefully you know
I always tell myself I'm not gonna get
upset but you just can't help it well
you talked to Tom Brady you guys are
friends yeah he's doing good
you know he's handle it better than I
did he came to visit me we were doing
some addition he's the quarterback out
of team
what is energy Sam is like it's just the
game he's like yeah it's just a game and
your wife and you look at Gronkowski
who's he's got one bad leg but yet he's
got a Super Bowl party dancing after how
to do that same thing bucket fault
Tom feels like they're gonna win this
year they finally got a great defense
last year they didn't have any defense
he was pretty much him in the offense
that got him there so